welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
House of the Dragon episode 10 the
season finale The Black Queen in this
video is brought to you by Pluto TV the
free streaming platform offering free
movies and shows that are 100 free 100
of the time this finale is exactly why I
don't bring my mighty rescue dog to the
dog park damn it darling now we gotta
run before Karen Gulch throws you in her
bike basket let us break down this epic
finale frame by frame for the Game of
Thrones connections easy to miss details
and deeper layers of meaning quick
detail about the opening credits when we
see the stone dial Serena and Damon's
kids aegon the younger in bezeris there
is not a third dial for Virginia even
though past instances have shown dials
for unborn descendants waiting for the
bloodline to reach them already
predestined on that stone but since
vicinity was never going to live there
is no dial for her we opened on aegon
the conquerors painted table showing the
northern part of Westeros the wall and
the castle at the West End of the wall
shadow Tower basically the Northwestern
tip of the Known World from the
targaryen's perspective the camera
Glides down past Winterfell white Harbor
the barrel lens moat Kalin the neck and
other towns this is essentially how
every episode of Game of Thrones would
begin the camera gliding down over a map
of Westeros we're near a second son Luke
runs his hand across driftmark and
restates his hesitation to take over
driftmark as lord of the tides something
he told corlies back in episode 7. from
the little drift block it means
everyone's dead for Luke his role is a
pawn and the schemes of the adults has
always haunted him for him with Duty
comes death renera says we don't choose
our destiny Luke it chooses us again
coming back to the stone dials the
opening credits each style for every
living descendant is preset in stone
before the bloodline even reaches it all
this is part of a destined path the
bloodline chooses the person when you're
promises Luke that she will prepare him
for his duties as her father prepared
her oh no this scene takes on a new
layer of irony after the episode's
ending Ranier cannot possibly prepare
Luke for his Bloodshed that's to come
just as viserys couldn't possibly
prepare renera for the treachery that
would engulf the realm after his death
sir Lawrence Mar brand one of the few
Knights of the seven Kings guard we
haven't met yet until this point
announces rhaenys has arrived with
melies Ace gets right to the news
officers death and she continues there
is more
Egon has been crowned as his successor
yes Ranier wins is from a contraction
right as she hears the news of aegon
supplanting her but even from the moment
rainy said there is more notice how
Rainier gets hit with a bit of the
dizzies as if she is bracing for that
other shoe to drop it's fun to watch
Damon in the scene clearly all he can
think about is how someone murdered his
brother from the moment he sniffed that
milk of the poppy and viserys's cup in
episode 8. we should note that Lyman
beesbury also jumped to the conclusion
of regicide Rainey says the high septon
crowned aegon in the dragon pit I
witnessed it myself just before I fled
on melees yeah it seems like just the
mention of aegon's name triggers another
early contraction the rushed crowning of
her half-brother sinks with the rushed
crowning of her child and I love Ramin
jawadi's music here
yeah it sounds like jawadi's using some
rock Distortion maybe some electric
cello electric upright bass recalls Hans
Zimmer's music for Inception the opening
[Music]
the opening booms of Edith Pia's song
slow down to convey the countdown of a
dream coming to an end for an era time
is also running out and viserys's dream
of the Dragons roaring as one is also
coming to an end now Damon who has spent
most of this season silent motor mounts
threw some commands in this finale than
he does in the entire other Nine
episodes put together if the greens
attack now it will be by stealth
not directly we don't have enough men to
surround the island but we can make
ourselves appear stronger than they are
throughout all this we're near his pain
the screams echo through the
kitchen trying to carry out business by
comparison the red keep is more closed
off and segmented so the physical state
of the Sovereign there can be kept
hidden but here everyone in Dragonstone
knows everything it's that open concept
interior design it always gets you also
demon is echoing his brother viserys
about the true nature of Targaryen power
it's a trick it's an illusion casting a
large Shadow to make your enemies think
you're more of a threat than you
actually are Jace and Luke's Spar on the
beach as Jace goes way too hard on his
younger brother showing how Luke is just
a sweet summer child he is not prepared
for this war the two boys are brought in
front of Ranier while she is in labor
because she is worried she might die the
way her mother Emma did and she wants to
make sure Jace knows that he is her Heir
whatever happens to her he asks where is
Damon I don't know
gone to Madness
gone to plot his War yeah plot his War
renira recognizes that Damon was already
looking for any excuse to wage war
against the greens Damon's Council
continues to scheme with plans to reach
out to allies and the crownlands
including house darklin that's her
Stefan's house from duskendale house
Massey from Stone dance and House Bar
Eman from sharp Point Damon plans to fly
to riverrun to secure house Tully and he
refuses to check in with a maester and
ignores Jason first if you think about
it trying to Stage his own coup until he
is called out now the most vocal Lord at
all these meetings other than Damon is
bartimos celtegar the wealthy Lord of
claw Isle in the crownlands and a key
member of Rainier's Council going
forward Damon takes Luke to force sir
Lauren to enter Stefan to reaffirm their
allegiance to renera and in this scene
he could see the burns on Damon's neck
which Damon actually received when he
got hit with that flaming arrow during
the prior battles for the staff Stones
back at the beginning of episode three
just love the continuity there Damon
uses karaxi's to intimidate the knights
foreign
slips a little on that Boulder just a
reminder that these dragons are not
perfect Majestic Godly creatures they're
awkward somewhat clumsy Oaks who are too
big for this world and not entirely in
control and so we should not expect them
to perfectly obey their boyish Masters
commands in the final battle Damon says
that if the Knight Sinclair their
loyalty to the usurper now they'll get a
clean death but if they turn their coats
later know that you will die
screaming
and we cut to raniera screaming herself
close to death her labor pains intercut
with these shots of a dragon we think it
might be Cyrax but it actually might be
another one which she envisions her
unborn child to be because in the text
the baby vesenia is a stillborn as it is
in the show but the biased account of
mushroom claims that the child was born
with dragon-like birth defects including
a stubby scaled tale here Rainier does
scream get it out which is a slight
change from her line of the book monster
monster get it out obviously the scene
is horrifying and extremely
uncomfortable to watch I'm not gonna go
into the visuals of it but I will say it
looked like the umbilical cord was
wrapped around the throat as opposed to
this baby having some dragon-like birth
defects but Rainier's fear of giving
birth to a literal Dragon does remind us
of her mother Emma's line in episode one
after this miserable pregnancy
I wouldn't be surprised if I hatched an
actual Dragon it is a reminder that
dragons and dreams are the strength of
this family but they're also their own
downfall the child's remains are burned
on altar in the same spot where Rainier
and Damon were married in the secret
ceremony at the end of episode 7 Sir
Eric Cargill arrives and presents king
viserys's crown meaning he must have
stolen it from the corpse perhaps during
aegon's crowning in the dragon pit or in
the aftermath and the book sits are
Stefan darklin who steals the crown he
reaffirms his kingsguard vows and Damon
takes the crown looks at it closely
notice to the right of the Targaryen
sigil is the lion of House Lannister on
the other side of it which we see when
it's on her head is the Tully fish and
the Baratheon stag all the major houses
are represented on this Crown this is a
crown worn by King jaharis Damon crowns
reniro just as he placed this crown on
the head of his brother in episode 8. in
both cases you do get the sense that
Damon wanted this crown for himself but
just had to resign to hand it off to
another Damon kneels followed by
everyone else but not rainis she later
said she must wait for her Lord husband
Corliss to decide the fealty of house
Valerian before she can bend the knee to
anyone but you also get the sense that
as the queen Who Never Was she's always
been Queen in her own mind candles are
lit on a tray that slid underneath the
painted table to illuminate the dragon
glass from beneath like aegon the
conqueror's dagger secrets were hidden
by pyromancers that are only revealed by
fire Queen renera is marched in and she
takes the same route through Dragonstone
that Daenerys does in that Game of
Thrones season 7 Long Walk promo
remember how great that was that was
like the first footage of Game of
Thrones we got after the season six
finale might have been the last time
everyone still like Game of Thrones oh
The Nostalgia so the painted table
illuminates and we see the south end of
it only extends to the stormlands Dorne
was not included on the conquerors table
because it was the one part of the
continent that he was unable to conquer
I also love the Mufasa in this of this
everything the light touches is our
kingdom Jace assumes the role of placing
the figurines on the map on Dragonstone
he places the Targaryen sigil the
tallest one that's painted black on
King's Landing the Hightower Lighthouse
painted green as Rainier walks in she
awkwardly has to Signal her escort to
stop following her she's new to this and
she's still figuring out the protocol of
moving like a ruler we learned that
Reina is Rainier's cupbearer as raniero
was a cup Bearer to viserys it's very
important role because renera includes
Reina at the table along with her sister
Bella moves that she clearly made to
appeal to rhaenys who supports she is
still angling to secure greniere proves
herself a very competent ruler in the
way that she handles rhaenys for the
house is already declaring their names
they Mark with black figurines on the
table for their enemies they Mark with
the green figurines and for the ones
that they are targeting as flippable
like winterpell River Run the Erie and
Storm's end they Mark with golden ones
Daemon does some Dragon math for us they
have three adults by my count we have
Cyrax
character Max arax and tyraxes Baylor
has Moon dances yeah I love that
reaction shot on rainy's having her
Dragon conscripted without her consent
just like the greens try to do to her
and King's Landing last episode Damon
goes on there are also unclaimed dragons
see smoke still resides on driftmark
Verma Thor and Silverwing dwell on the
dragon mount
still rideless
then there are the three wild dragons
all of whom Nest here yes confirming
lanor's Dragon sea smoke remains on
drift Market did not follow him to essos
Verma Thor the bronze Fury was the
dragon of jeheris first Silverwing was
the dragon of jairus's wife alisane the
dragon she famously flew to Winterfell
and the wall also yes he probably
noticed we cut to Arena right after
Damon says some dragons are writerless
because she remains that one of these
kids not to be bonded with a dragon for
now so Damon adds it up 13 dragons for
the blacks four for the greens he says
four even though he only mentioned three
the Fourth Dragon is tasarion the sea
dragon that is written by Alison's
fourth child Darren who is left off
screen this season but confirmed to have
been in Old Town all this time we're
gonna meet him in season two Damon says
we need a place to gather a toehold
large enough to house a sizeable host
here at Harren Hall we cut off the West
surroundings Landing with the dragons
and we could have every green head
mounted on spikes before the Moon Turns
harrenhal was where the season began in
that great Council of 101. now it's
interesting how harrenhal is written on
the map but not the God's eye lake or
any of the geographic features only the
cities are labeled I think it shows how
the Conqueror didn't really care as much
about the land or the rivers we did
learn a couple episodes back that he
just cut down cut down the trees makes
sense because on Dragon back he could
soar over all of this he really only
cares about the people and their castles
by the way the page for hair and all has
apparently been the most viewed fandom
wiki page for a location all season long
we've been big fans of their wikis for
Star Wars the MCU and House of the
Dragon they're the world's largest fan
Wiki platform and we thank them for
partnering with us on this breakdown Sir
Eric announces Otto's arrival a shift is
besides offshore alone gallium plan a
banner of a three-headed Green Dragon
now we do not see these ships but the
description tells us how the greens have
co-opted the Targaryen Sigil of the 300
Dragon but instead of it being black or
Crimson they made it green which
fittingly is also the color of their
largest dragon vegar Damon meets Otto on
the same bridge where they faced off in
episode two and just like in that
encounter rhaenyra arrives late after
the other is on Dragon back Landon Cyrax
behind Otto's group and walks through
these Knights completely unafraid
Targaryen rulers traditionally arrived
at their coronations on Dragon back but
that is something they could not manage
for aegon last episode so renera is
proving she has a symbolic power of her
own Otto offers his terms but renera
calls him a traitor and tosses his hand
pin or while produces a message sent
from Allison the page that renira tore
out of the history book in episode 1 in
the godswood the one describing their
Warrior Queen in nymeria princess of the
rhoynar who conquered Doran and famously
burned her Fleet to keep her people in
Westeros and promote peace this page
reads lashed together with ropes and
cables nymeria's Fleet dispersed at the
coming of the first storms sweeping them
across the sea east west and south into
something invested pocket at the
Basilisk Isles now the Basilisk Isles
are a group of islands in the summer see
off the coast of sopharus that's the
southern continent of this world another
reminder that HBO does have in the works
a nymeria spin-off so all the mentions
of nymeria this season is probably
setting it up but with this page Allison
is using not her own words but a memory
these two women shared when they were
still friends and a historical example
of a warrior Queen bravely dismantling
her most prized weapon her Fleet in the
name of Peace as she prays Rainier will
do by restraining her use of dragons
Damon again proposes fire against fire
it's no easy thing for a man to be a
dragon slayer
the dragons can kill dragons and have
and this line is spoken with Luke
centered most in the background who ends
up being the first victim of Dragon vs
Dragon conflict in the Civil War but
renira Echoes Daenerys at least season
seven Daenerys when dragons flew to war
everything burned
I do not wish to rule over a kingdom of
Ash and Bone
and so Damon snaps Ranier clears the
room we should note that all these
conversations Around The Song of Ice and
Fire only come up when maesters and
other Witnesses are not in the room
explaining why they would not have shown
up in the biased text of Fire and Blood
Damon chokes his wife my brother was a
slave to his omen's importance
anything to make his feckless rain a bit
of purpose
Dream City makers Kings
dragon's dead yeah Demon's perfectly
inverting what viserys told renera that
dragons were not the root of their power
dany's the dreamer was and dreams are
and Rainier realizes I never told you
yes she's rubbing it in that Damon was
never seriously considered to be
viserys's Heir otherwise viserys would
have shared aegon's dream with him all
this time Rainier had assumed that Damon
must have known it too and only now she
realizes that she has this over him
Pluto TV has on demand in linear
channels curated by real people who
select the movies and channels that you
love some of your favorite binge-worthy
shows and movies have their own channels
that you can watch 24 7. rainies tells
Corliss a stranger costs a long Shadow
over this family now episode 8 raynes
refused to look away from bayman's
Corpse preferring to stare at the
stranger directly remember in the Game
of Thrones era house valarion isn't
really around we did go into the series
knowing that we would be following a
house stalked by The Stranger Corliss
wants to retire and declare for no one
but renice says Rainier is the one
person showing her strength and all this
so when Corliss and rainey's join the
council they both now wear black to
match renera both in mourning for
viserys you could say but also to
Telegraph their allegiance to the blacks
Bayla and Reina joined Jace and Luke at
the end of the table which seems very
choreographed probably to show everyone
in the room the future of the black
succession through the valerians we
should note this choreography also
likely involved having Damon sit out of
this council meeting to avoid his
hot-headedness turning off Corliss or
rainies Rainier hopes for the support of
House's Aaron Stark and Baratheon hope
is the Fool's Ally
both Aaron and Baratheon share blood
with my house just a reminder that the
Aarons married into the targaryens
through veneer's mother Emma who died in
the first episode and the baratheons
have always been close to the targaryens
first through Oris Baratheon egg on the
conqueror's hand and his granddaughter
Jocelyn Baratheon married viserys's
Uncle Eamon and their daughter was
rhaenys Corliss glances back at his
betrothed's grandchildren and swears
support for ranera calling her your
grace and from his point of view notice
how rainy stands directly behind Ramirez
so Corliss isn't just bowing to the
queen he's also bowing to his wife the
queen Who Never Was and Corliss
announces a big strategic advantage that
they have one control over the
stepstones and can blockade shipping
lanes to King's Landing now this is
called the gullet this is a body of
water between Dragonstone and driftmark
and Massey's hook connecting the
Blackwater Bay to the narrow sea raynes
offers to patrol the gullet with melees
Jace offers to send himself and his
brother to the Erie to King's Landing
into Storm's end and notice as he does
Luke looks like he's about to [ __ ]
bricks so renira agrees she sends Jace
to talk with Lady Jane Aaron this is the
Lady of whom Damon in episode 5 at the
wedding said he wanted to talk about his
claim of runestone in the book Lady Jane
flat out denies Damon and then Jace will
go on to the younger Craig and Stark at
Winterfell will likely meet both Greg
and Stark and Lady Jane in season two
now renera advises her sons it's been
said that as targaryens we are closer to
Gods than to men the Iron Throne puts us
a touch closer perhaps but if we are to
serve the Seven Kingdoms we must answer
to their gods
she makes them both swear on a religious
text of the faith of the seven to not
fight now aegon the Conqueror adopted
the faith of the seven for the Targaryen
family to make it easier for the noble
houses of Westeros to accept Valyrian
Invaders despite what would happen the
family's tradition of polygamy and
incest conflicting with acceptance this
is similar pragmatism coming from
reniere here however we should note that
the Starks are more aligned with the old
gods Three Dragons depart Dragonstone
Vermax in front with Jace writing and
then I believe that's melees rainis
Dragon because I think you can see her
white hair there and then in the back
the noticeably smaller RX written by
Luke you can actually see Luke nervously
turning his head around to get one last
look at Dragonstone and you cannot help
but worry about the small dragon and
this kid as they head into storm clouds
during all this Damon heads into the
dragonmont singing a Valyrian lullaby as
he courts Verma Thor again this was J
Harris's dragon and it's interesting for
Damon to be the one accordion Burma Thor
because in the book it's another
character who does this also targaryens
don't commonly have multiple dragons at
the same time except Daenerys with her
three dragons though she was a weird
exception in all kinds of ways maybe
Damon saw corrects he's slipping earlier
at that sorry gold pup time for me to
level up so I can match vegar now as to
why Damon is singing him courting his
grandfather jaharis's Dragon takes us
back to the opening scene this season
the great council at 101 presided over
by jaharis and harrenhal and jaharis
likely also knew aegon's Song of Ice and
Fire so now Damon may be singing his own
Song of Ice and Fire as he claims
another part of jaharas's legacy and he
could see this with Damon reflected in
Burma Thor's eye and Burma Thor
reflected in Damon's eye the poster of
the series made the shape of the dragon
eye aegon's dagger so this is kind of
and writing his own Song of Ice and Fire
we return to Storm's end in the
lightning Luke sees vegar's massive bulk
outside the castle walls looming over
the battlements like freaking Godzilla
it's jowls hanging low inside aemond is
already chatting with Boris daughter
Maris the other three Cassandra Ellen
and Flores are literally lined up as if
Boris is auctioned them off to any
prince who walks in boros calls for a
maester to read renira's message since
he's illiterate hit Leah Michelle a
maester since Luke has already betrothed
boros sends him away before he goes
Eamon taunts Luke calling him Lord
strong neither Prince nor villarian and
reminds him of his debt
I want you to put out your eye aim in
one eye keeps a massive sapphire in his
eye socket showing us why his opening
credit style has included a sapphire so
while we're near and Allison have an
understanding at least for now their
sons still bear the scars from their
youths it was Luke who brought in the
pink dread look who cut out eamon's eye
look who laughed at the roasted pig in
episode 7. he said it's coming and in
episode 4 in this same Storm's end round
Hall we saw two young Lords from Bracken
and Blackwood draw swords on each other
spilling blood though the younger Lord
was Victorious there so if you don't
know what happens this really does feel
like it can go either way but Boris
forbids fighting inside the keep but
that doesn't stop Eamon from pursuing
actually in the book it's Mars Baratheon
who eggs on Eamonn she asks did Lucas to
move your balls as well as your eyes why
you gotta say anything Maris when Luke
greets RX in the storm outside now when
the lightning strikes no vegar is
visible it's loose waiting for him in
the shadows like in Jaws or any great
horror film The Monster is scariest when
you don't know where it is director Greg
etanus nailed the sequence with
excellent usage of lighting textures and
sound design set in heavy VFX sequences
like this during rainstorms is always a
smart move despite the difficulties to
the actors and the production crew
because lightning allows flashes to show
the action and water allows the surfaces
to reflect the light better so that we
can see everything more clearly and the
textures look more realistic that way
that's partly why the T-Rex attack in
Jurassic Park in the Battle of Helms
Deep and two towers are so grippy and
Vivid you see this usage of lighting and
texturing especially in this real wide
shot as RX flaps away from Storm's end
one lightning strike shows us the tower
and then a few more reflect different
parts of rx's body and wings to show it
slowly moving away like too slow we're
all watching this feeling Jesus Christ
hurry get the [ __ ] out of there and the
storm also serves a practical function
Luke is sprayed with rain making it
impact possible for him or for RX to see
forward as Luke looks around dizzy
looking for vegar behind him vegar has
finally revealed looming above them like
a freaking Star Destroyer this huge
Dragon pass is completely overhead
before Luke even sees it and then vegar
rushes directly at them
yeah notice how there was no music
before this point just the terrifying
sounds of the storm but right as
Lightning reveals Vegas form rushing at
us we hear this percussive clash in
jawadi's music kicks in Eamon laughs and
he taunts I see you recalling that
creepy glance he gave Luke in the
courtyard in episode 8 Luke takes RX
through a narrow Canyon where vagar
can't follow we get a close-up of
vegard's Reigns The netting of rope
that's used to climb up onto the dragon
reminder that these loose ropes are
really the only way Eamon can tug at
beigar to Pilot the dragon and control
it and when ropes are wet they're more
elastic and less likely to pull taut
Luke loses control of RX who sprays fire
at bagar
foreign
big mistake but an interesting layer of
context that wasn't in the book Eamon
and Luke here do not want their dragons
to kill each other whereas in the book
Eamon isn't playing games he is filled
with pure homicidal range and Vengeance
this isn't a dance between the boys
anymore it's a dance of the Dragons Luke
flies high above the storm clouds and
briefly he gets this heavenly view of it
all but it's a false victory
oh damn and again they've deliberately
include Eamon screaming vegar no which
is a huge contrast to the book Eamon who
goes even further to desecrate Luke's
remains afterward and he could just make
out Luke's body falling among the bloody
pieces of RX we're reminded of Luke's
brother Jace struggling to translate the
High Valyrian words for killed versus
Feld and not knowing the word for mouth
so Eamonn screaming no is another
example of this series softening these
characters making them less treacherous
and bloodthirsty than they are in the
text so that we as viewers can better
empathize with them as characters on
several seasons of a TV series you could
read this as a producers learning
lessons from Daenerys in the final
episodes of Game of Thrones who
willfully committed war crimes on Dragon
back when just having Daenerys scream
drogon know as drogon torches King's
Landing might have been more true for
her character and I would argue make the
conflict between her and Jon Snow in the
final episode even more interesting
because he wouldn't be killing a
freaking evil war criminal he'd be
killing someone whose power is just too
out of control but thematically for this
series House of the Dragon I like how it
keeps the focus on the dragon power as
the chaotic threat that makes it
impossible for even the most rational
leaders to succeed and it proves viserys
right the dragons are too big for this
world and the idea that targaryens can
control dragons is a complete myth the
targaryens are just lucky that dragons
will let them ride them this episode
ends on Damon telling renira the news
and she stumbles a bit as she clutches
her stomach as if that pain of losing
her child is hitting her all over again
also noticed in the scene Ranier is not
wearing the crown she's reacting to this
not as a queen here but as a mother and
as she turns around in Rage any
negotiation with the black queen is off
the table a painted table of Westeros
now lit From Below making it look like
the continent of Westeros is on fire and
soon it will be it has been a pleasure
breaking down this season of House of
the Dragon with you all I so appreciate
your patience waiting the day longer for
a deeper dive from a nerd with just a
plain American accent thanks again to
Pluto TV for sponsoring this episode
Pluto tv offers free live channels and
on-demand blockbuster movies stream now
pay never follow me on tick tock
Instagram and Twitter at a boss follow
me Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]